please welcome jennifer lopez to perform  this land as your land and america the  beautiful accompanied by members  of the president's own united states  marine band  me  [Applause]  [Music]  this land is your land  this land is  from california  to the new york islands  from the redwood forest  to the gulf stream waters  this land was made for you and  me as i went walking  down that ribbon of  [Music]  this land was made for you and me  oh this land  all this land  this land was made for you and  [Music]  [Music]  america  [Music]  with brotherhood  [Music]  from sea to  [Music]  shiny  [Music]  [Music]  let's  this land was made for you  [Music]  and  [Music]  me  [Applause]  you